이거 좀 열어보세요.
이런 거 어떠세요?
두 개 가지고 있으면 기분이 좋아요.
재밌는 거 하고 있는 데는 다 중국 회사예요.
그러니까 로브락을 가전으로 보시나요?
그럼 가전 상황 시장은 좀 바꿔 논의를 좀 확장해서
앞으로 이 시장이 좀 어떻게 바뀔 거라고 보시나요?
소비자들이 값어치를 브랜드보다는
그거 아까 말씀하셨던
소비문화인문의 경제 이야기 비주류 경제와 호스트를 맡은
저는 토스 김창선이고요.
저는 재무덕후 이재용입니다.
이번 주 비주류 경제학 주제는 가전인데요.
게스트로 나의 시선 최문균님 모셨습니다.
어서 오세요.
반갑습니다.
안녕하세요.
네, 반갑습니다.
나의 시선님은 블로거, 유튜버로도 유명하시지만
얼리어덥터라는 단어를 처음 국내에 들여온 분이라고 들었어요.
맞나요?
그렇죠. 옛날 단어죠.
제가 98년도인가 그때
저희 매형이 미국에서 전화가 왔어요.
그래서 얼리어덥터라고
얼리어덥터라는 단어가 있는데
너 같대요.
저 같대요.
그래서 빨리 도메인을 사라고 그러더라고요.
사업적인 소환이 살짝 있으셨네요.
그래서 그때 사놨죠.
사놨다가 그래서 사이트를 열었어요.
근데 정말 많은 얼리어덥터들이 있더라고요.
사이트 가입자를 어떻게 모으신 건데요?
처음에 제가 가지고 있는 제품들 막 자랑하는 그런 것부터 시작을 했거든요.
내가 산 거, 구한 거 이런 것들.
거기 관심 있는 사람들이 많이 들어왔어요.
그분들이 얼리어덥터여서.
그러면 사실상 그 얼리어덥터라는 사이트가 1세대 테크리뷰 사이트 이렇게 봐도 되겠네요.
시조새.
아, 시조새.
조상님.
그러면 그렇게 프로 리뷰어로 활동하시다가 아이리버에 합류하시게 됐어요.
아이리버에는 어떻게 좀 합류하신 거예요?
얼리어덥터 활동을 많이 하다 보니까 강의도 많이 하고
그리고 컨설팅도 많이 하고 그렇게 됐어요.
그래서 컨설팅 많이 하다가 아이리버 라는 곳에서
컨설팅 의뢰가 들어왔는데
첫 미팅하고 나서 되게 제가 빠졌어요.
너무 재밌더라고요.
어떤 제품들을 기획하고 만드셨어요?
대표적인 건 아무래도 미키마우스 플레이어.
미키마우스?
네.
뭐 클릭스, 디플 이런 전자사전 이런 것들 많이 만들었었죠.
그 당시만 해도 아이리버가 거의 이제 느낌상으로는 음향기기 쪽에서는 소니 같은 느낌.
음.
아, 이거죠.
MP3는 아이리버가.
그래서 그 정보를 들어야 된다라는 느낌이 있었던 것 같아요.
맞습니다.
근데 궁금한 게 이제 한창 아이리버에서 활동하실 시기에
바다 건너 미국에서는 이제 아이폰이라는 게 이제 공개가 되고
그 소문이 막 들려올 거 아니에요.
아이폰이라는 게 나왔다.
그때 좀 어떠셨는지 궁금해요.
아이폰이 세상에 나왔을 때.
실제로 미국 애플스토어 가서 줄 서 샀어요.
아이폰 1을.
네.
이거를 가서 우리 아이리버 친구들 한테 보여줘야 되나
전의를 상실할까 말아야 되나 이런 게 진짜로 나왔구나
왜냐면 사실은 우리도 다 예측을 했었고 기회도 있었던 거 같아요
근데 그렇게 못 간 게 되게 아쉬워요
그러면 본인이 그런 아름다운 제품을 만져보는
얼리어답터로서의 정체성이 강하다고 생각하세요
아니면 내가 그런 걸 만들어 봐야겠다는
메이커로서의 정체성이 강하다고 생각하세요
저는 역시 제품을 고르고 선택하고
이 사람한테 어떤 제품이 맞는지
그런 것들을 셀렉트해 주는 거를 너무너무 좋아해요
주변 지인들한테도 뭐 이런 거
너한텐 이게 맞아 이런 식으로 많이 하세요?
어 그럼요
마침 그래서 오늘 저희한테 약간 좀 추천해 주고 싶은
소개해 주고 싶은 제품을 준비하셨다고
별 건 아닌데
너무 궁금해요 지금
너무 부담되게 그러지 마세요
별 건 아닌데
제가 무슨 박스를
네 박스 여기 있습니다
이거 좀 열어보세요
이게 제가 주변 분들한테 선물 드리는 박스거든요
선물을 주는 박스
이거는 좀 이따 설명드릴 거고
이렇게 들어있어요
그래서 제가 두 분한테 선물 드리고 싶은데
두 분의 취향을 제가 잘 모르니까
제 취향에 맞는 제품들을 그냥 가져왔어요
그래서 여기서 아마
제가 리액션을 보면은 두 분 취향을 알 수 있을 것 같아요
아 일단 재용님이 한번 마음에 드는 거 하나 보내보시죠
그걸 잡아서 잡았어요
아 잡았어요 초콜릿
초콜릿 아몬드 앤 씨솔트
짭짤한 초콜릿인가봐요
이건 그냥 제가 맛있어서
맛있어 보인다
이런 거 어떠세요?
이런 거 계산기
계산기 회계사한테 딱이죠
딱이 아니라 약간 질색하는 느낌인데?
이 계산기는 미국의 초등학생들이 수업 시간에 배우는 계산기예요
아 실제로요?
디자인된 뭔가가 아니라
그래서 이런 거를 줘요
선생님용
알려주는 거구나
이렇게 계산기는 이렇게 하는 거야
1하고 0하고 더하기 하면 돼
근데 제가 생각하기에 제일 예뻐요
음
빈색으로 되게 진하게 잘 빠졌어요
제가 눈에 띄는 건 이 노란 박스 이건데
이건 뭘까요?
이거는 고드밀러라는 회사인데
자동차 안에서 쓸 수 있는 티슈예요
아 티슈구나
컵홀더에 딱 들어가는 사이즈로
사실 티슈들이 어디에 꽂을 수가 없잖아요
그리고 우리 주유소에서 주유하고 받으면
티슈 그냥 이렇게 흐물흐물한 비닐 안에 담겨있어서
계속 굴러다니잖아요
글로벌 박스에 넣어놓는데
그래서 그냥 거기다가 꽂을 수 있는 티슈예요
아 진짜 이거 여기서 이제 한 장씩 뽑는 거잖아요 이렇게
아 진짜 단순한데 딱 필요한 쓰임을 찾아서 디자인한 것 같아요
이거 한번 이 책을 한번
어 어디에요?
와일드쌤이라는 출판사인데
굉장히 작은 출판사예요
근데 이 출판사의 특이한 점은 뭐냐면
나라별의 가이드 북을 만드는데
그 나라가 한 1년 살아요
살면서 뭘 하냐면
책을 쓰는 게 아니라
거기 있는 음식점들에 셰프들이랑 친해져요
그래서 그 셰프들한테
너가 자주 가는 맛집 정보 좀 내놔
그래서 그 맛집 정보를 모아요
그래서 저기다 넣어요
입소문으로 들은 얘기들로 해가지고
발로 취재를 해서 이렇게 모으면
찐 현지인 맛집 리스트를 만들자
진짜로
진짜의 정보를 저기다 넣어서
그래서 그 안에 막 지도도 나오고 그렇거든요
근데 지도도 보면은
우리가 알 수 없는 지도예요
자기들이 생각하기에 중요한 곳이 크게 부각이 되어 있는 그런 지도도 있고
그다음에 그 음식점을 가기 위해서 걸어간다
그럼 걸어갈 때 보면 너무 좋은 수필
뭐 이런 것들을 담아놓은 아주 독특한 책이에요
재밌다
전 세계 온갖 가이드북이 있는데
딱 완전 로컬에 집중해가지고
현지 사람들의 목소리로만 채워진 그런 가이드북이네요
그래서 책이 저렇게도 만들어질 수 있구나 그런 생각을 했죠
와
아니 이렇게 많은 물건들 엄청 많이 준비해 주셨는데
다들 뭔가 사연이나 이야기들이
그러니까 하나에 다 이야기들이 다 녹아있네
그러니까요 아기자기해하네요
감사합니다
나의 시선님이 이렇게 준비해 준 물건들도 잔뜩 봤는데
결국 궁금한 건
나의 시선님이 좋은 물건을 고르는 기준이 뭔지가 좀 궁금해요
아...
저 이 질문 되게 많이 봤거든요
되게 많이 봤는데
음 저는
제품을 이렇게 점점 점점 쓰면서 스며들어서 좋아지는 제품보다
첫눈에 확 끌리는 제품이 좋은 것 같아요
아 그래요
근데 그게 디자인적인 것만은 아니에요
굉장히 여러 가지 복합적인 건데
제가 생각하는 디테일
그 디테일이 제품을 깊이 알고
스토리를 파헤치고 이러다 보면은
그 제품을 만든 사람의 의도가 보여요
수세미 하나를 골라도
수세미 너무 중요해요
수세미까지 중요하면
왜 수세미에 수세미의 모양이 다 네모난데
어떤 건 동그랗잖아요
그리고 거기에 왜 눈하고 입이 뚫려 있는지
스크럽 대도 거기에 젓가락이든 숟가락이든 끼워서 닦을 수 있게
어 제품 좀 아시네요
네네 저도 관심이 많아서
스크럽 좀 하셨는데
그런 디테일들까지 다 보면서 구입을 하시는 거예요
저희가 이제 이번 주제가 가전이니까
한번 가전으로 좁혀서 얘기를 해보면은
네 네 저도 관심이 많아서
나의 시선님이 요즘 정말 갖고 싶은 가전 제품이 있나요?
없더라고요
아 그래요?
그렇게 많이 소개하시는데도 불구하고
정작 내가 갖고 싶어 하는 거랑 좀 거리가 있나 보네요
저는 약간 폭풍전야 같아요
어 지금 폭풍전야다
그런 소식이 조만간 들려올 거고
저는 가전 시장이
예전에는 가전 시장, IT 시장, 카메라 시장
이렇게 분화돼 있었잖아요
그게 통합될 것 같아요
그게 오히려 통합될 것 같아요
더 세분화되는 게 아니라
제품 자체는 세분화될 텐데
이건 가전이다, 이건 IT다
이런 어떤 구분이 티미해질 것 같아요
티미해질 것 같다
왜냐하면은 지금도 어떤 그런 제품들이 나오고 있는데
예를 들면 냉장고에 물건을 넣는다 그러면은
카메라가 읽어서 AI가 분석을 해서
이게 뭐 얼만큼 남았다 이런 것들을
동기화는 알려줬구나
근데 그게 지금 신기한데
2, 3년 후가 되면은 너무 당황하죠?
당연한 게 될 것 같고요
예전으로 얘기하는 가전으로 나오건 IT로 나오건
그건 중요하지가 않죠
그래서 그런 게 트렌드가 되지 않을까
모든 것들이 다 섞인다라는 느낌으로 변할 거다
이번에는 재용 님 차례인데
가전이라는 산업의 특징
간단히 좀 티징을 해주시면
일단 가전 같은 경우는
전체 글로벌한 규모로 따지면
아주 정확한 통계는 없습니다만
대략한 우리나라 돈으로 900조에서 1,000조 가까운 시장이고요
1,000조 가까운 시장이고요
큽니다
TV, 냉장고, 세탁기 엄청 크잖아요
그 특징은 이제 성장세가 그렇게 가파르지 않다
대략 최근 10년간 연 평균 한 5% 내외
꾸준히 성장은 하는데
왜냐면 이제 글로벌한 경기가 성장은 하니까
20년 전에도 TV, 냉장고, 세탁기는 다 있었으니까
지금도 이미 똑같은 TV, 냉장고, 세탁기니까
성장세는 그렇게 높지 않다
이것도 좀 궁금한데
가전에서 그런 어마어마한 자본력을 바탕으로 한
유통이 중요한지
아니면 정말 날카로운 기술력이 중요한지
당연히 둘 다 중요하긴 한데
생각해 보면은 이제 아무래도 덩치가 큰 제품이 많고
지역별로 좀 필요한 어떤 특성이 좀 다르다 보니까
유통이 조금 더 중요한 거 같다
왜냐면 AS를 일단 해줘야 되고
그런 생각이 들었는데요
왜 그런 생각을 했냐면
점유율을 생각해 보면
다른 산업들은 막 뭐 10%, 20% 굉장히 높은
점유율을 가지고 있는 기업들이 어떤 산업인 다 있는데
가전은 10%, 20%를 가지고 있는 기업들이 다 있는데
가전은 10%, 20%, 20%를 가지고 있는 기업들이 다 있는데
10% 이상의 점유율을 가진 회사가 없어요
우리가 알고 있는 삼성전자도 대략 글로벌하게 4%
LG도 4%, 도시바 3%, 하이얼 5%
뭔가 우리가 들어본 회사들도 다 대충 5% 언더예요
왜냐하면 지역별로 그 어떤 유통의 벽을 넘기가 힘든 거죠
왜냐하면 가전시장 강자들이 좀 이렇게 분절되어 있는 게
이 가전시장의 특징 중에 하나인 거 같아요
그건 특이하네요
스마트폰은 뭐 몇십 퍼센트 애플
몇십 퍼센트는 뭐
삼성 뭐 이렇게 큼직큼직한 땅을 가져가고 있는데
가전은 정말 작은 땅을 가져가고 있는데
스마트폰은 아무래도 소프트웨어가 중요하다 보니까
동일한 OS를 쓰면 전 세계에 이제 유통이 가능한데
아무래도 그런 가전 쪽은 소프트웨어보다는
하드웨어적인 특징이 중요하다 보니까
전 세계를 통일하는 업체들은 잘 안 나오는 거 같아요
근데 확실히 가전시장의 트렌드는 니치 마켓인 것 같긴 해요
스탠바이 미도 그렇고 음식물 처리 같은 것도 그런데
어떻게 보면은 대형 그런 TV 시장에서
되게 니치한 마켓을 잘...
개척한 제품이 스탠바이 미 같은 이런 이동형 TV인 거 같은데
매출 LG전자나 혹은 삼성전자의 매출에도 되게 유인이 할까요?
아무래도 이제 대략 추정해 보면은
1년에 한 2, 30만 개 팔 거라고 추정한 경우가 많더라고요
1년에 2, 30만 개
1년에 2, 30만 개인데 스탠바이 미가 보통 한 100만 원 정도 하거든요
그러면은 뭐 매출로 따지면 한 2천억에서 3천억 정도 돼요
이익도 잘 나올 것 같아요
못해도 한 20% 남기지 않을까 생각은 하는데
사실 LG전자가 조단위의 영업이익을 기록하는 회사니까
어마어마하게 막 이렇게 막 대단하다기보다는
한 뭐 1, 2% 정도의 어떤 쏠쏠한 정도의 제품이지
아 이걸로 막 이제 우리는 가자 약간 이 정도의 제품은 아닐 수도 있죠
근데 저는 요즘 가끔 보면은 약간 좀 억지로 띄우는 시장도 있는 것 같다는 생각이 좀 들었어요
그러니까 어떤 거냐면 그 스타일러 같은 것도
사실은 바람 부는 곳에 옷 말려놓고
그다음에 옷장에 걸어놓으면 되는 건데
그걸 굳이 가전화시켰다는 게
가전이 아닌 것까지도 가전화시키는 그런 느낌도 드는데
어떻게 보시는지도 궁금한데요?
저는 사놓고 후회한 제품이 스타일러입니다
아 정말요?
스타일러인데 처음에 좀 쓰다가
그 너무 좋았거든요 처음에는
근데 말씀하신 것처럼
옷의 냄새를 없애거나 할 수 있는 방법이 굉장히 여러 가지가 있고
더 효율적인 것 같아요
그래서 잘 안 쓰게 되니까 이게 자리를 차지하게 되는 거죠
그럼 그런 카테고리의 제품들은 리치마켓에서 시작을 하더라도
시간이 지나면 결국엔 사람들의 평가나 이런 거에 있어서
사라지는 카테고리가
아니면 변신을 하거나
변신을 하거나
더 획기적으로 좋아지거나
더 좋아지거나
그 로봇청소기가 그런 거죠
바퀴가 달려서 스타일러가 구석에 있다가
나와 이러면 바퀴 달려와요
거실로 나와가지고 돌리고 다시 이렇게 들어가고 접혀가지고
퇴근해서 집에 들어오면 스타일러가 반대하는 거야
면적이 문제니까 구석에 박혀있으면 되죠
그럼 재용 님이 이런 리치한 가전제품 중에서 써보신 것 중에 가장 만족하신 제품은?
이제는 리치가 아니죠
그리고 로봇청소기는 제가 로보락 거를 쓰는데
더 이상 리치 아닌 것 같아요
리치 아니죠 리치 아니죠 완전 메이스트림이고
필수품이고
확실히 로봇청소기는 기존의 핸디 청소기의 사용 비중이 현저하게 줄은 거는 맞는 것 같아서
로봇은 진짜 앞으로도 더 발전이 기대되는 카테고리인 것 같아요
로보락은 굉장히 첨단이에요
그러니까 로보락을 가전으로 보시나요?
그쵸 집에 굴러다니는 거니까
저는
저는 로봇청소기 처음에 볼 때 무조건 IT였거든요
IT기기다
IT인데 청소를 한다 이런 거였는데 지금 가전이죠
그게 아마 가전이 다른 IT라든지 여러 가지 AI라든지 다 합쳐질 수 있는 그런 얘기인 것 같아요
로보락은 좀 더 로보틱스 회사 같은 느낌으로 더 보시는 거군요
네 로보락 최근에 나온 제품은 팔이 달려서 다니면서 자꾸 어디서 양말 같은 걸 주워와요
음~~
이제 강아지랑 자꾸 싸우죠
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
강아지의 위협이
자기 장난감을 자꾸 집어가지고
쓰레를 생각해서 집어오니까
강아지에게 로봇의 위협이 벌써 닥치고 있네요
근데 아마 휴머노이드가 되면은 집 안에 조금 조금씩 들어오는 게 아니라 거의 사람을 대체하는 일들을
들어와서 하는 거죠
그쵸 근데 그게 얼마 안 남았어요
그것도 어쩌면 지금은 로봇 분야지만 가전 분야가 될 수도 있죠
음~~
그 중에는칼 우
음~~~
으음 unch
음 things
음~~
응
음~~~
경쟁이기 때문에 어떻게 하면 잘 만들까 너무 포커스를 하고 있는 것 같아요
더 높은 성능, 더 높은 기능. 잘 만드는 건 너무 당연한 거고
지금 중요한 것은 뭘 만들지죠. 저는 약간 떠오르는 게 다이슨이 이제 무선청소기로 한국 시장에 들어왔을 때
사실 삼성이나 LG 같은 경우가 그런 무선청소기를 굉장히 빨리 만들고 심지어 성능으로 더 뛰어난 제품을 만들면서
다이슨의 어떤 점유율을 크게 빼었었잖아요. 근데 그 이후에 로봇청소기라는 시장이 급부상하고 있었음에도 불구하고
약간 무선청소기 시장의 어떤 성능, 흡입력 이런 거에 집착을 한 나머지 약간 거기에 이렇게 뛰어드는 것, 몰입하는 것에 좀 늦어진 건 아닌가 이런 생각도 좀 들었어요
근데 또 모르죠. 뭐 휴머노이드 로봇들이 갑자기 크게 성장을 해서
네.
로봇청소기보다 일반 청소기가 더 중요해질 수도 있어요.
성능이 더 중요해질 수도 있겠죠.
휴머노이드가 작동시키는 로봇청소기.
근데 그 대응에 늦었던 건 사실인 것 같아요.
맞아요.
다만 이제 LG 같은 경우가 되게 특이한 게 숫자로 보는 거랑 조금 다른 문제에서 보면
저는 스탠바이 미 같은 걸 만든 걸 보면 보통은 그거를 시장조사를 하거나 아니면 서베이를 하거나 뭔가 그런 것들을 통해서 미래에 무슨 제품을 만들어야 되는지를
알거든요.
근데 이 제품은 그런 것 같지가 않아요.
그냥 내보냈다 일단.
그리고 제 생각에는 그 내부에 누군가가 나 이런 제품 필요해 그래서 만든 것 같아요.
그래서 우리나라에 되게 특이한 것 중에서 TV 볼 때 소파가 있으면 소파 앞에 테이블이 있거든요.
커피 테이블 같은 게 있는데 그 사이에 앉아서 보더라고요.
바닥에 앉아서.
앉아서 밥을 먹으면서 TV를 보죠.
네.
배달을 시켜놓고.
그게 우리나라만의 문화인 것 같아요.
근데 그렇게 보는 이유가 사실은 식탁도 있거든요.
다잉 테이블이 있는데.
TV 보면서 밥 먹으려고.
밥 먹으려고.
스탠바이 미가 있으면 그걸 가져와서.
식탁에 앉아서 볼 수 있으니까.
볼 수 있어요.
근데 그런 문화들이 그게 어떤 서베이나 그런 걸로 나오는 것 같지는 않아요.
그냥 일상 실생활에서 느꼈던 나의 페인 포인트를.
네.
그게 빠른 거죠.
트렌드를 적용하고 이런 게.
서베이는 해보면은 예전의 것.
혹은 소비자들은 상상을 하지 않고 자신의 현재를 얘기하거든요.
그래서 좀 앞에 미래에 어떤 문화가 일어날 거고 뭐가 어떻게 될 건지를 예측해야 되거든요.
맞아요.
근데 그렇게 하진 않은 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 그거는 하이 리스크 하이 리턴이기 때문에 그런 것 같거든요.
근데 지금은 하이 리스크 하이 리턴 할 때인 것 같아요.
미래에 뭐가 그러니까 지금 당장 보이는 결과는 없어도 미래에 이게 예측된다는 느낌이 있으면 빨리 일단 시도를 해 봐야 돼요.
네.
그리고.
저는 그런 점들을 알고 있고 하는 단계일 거고 그게 앞으로 어떤 결과물로 나오겠죠.
그걸 기대를 많이 하고 있습니다.
그러면 살짝 가정 카테고리에서 벗어나서 어떻게 보면 영상 가정 카테고리일 수도 있는데 DJI 이제 드론을 만드는 회사이지만 이제는 소형 카메라 마이크 심지어 얼마 전에는 로봇 청소기도 출시를 했더라고요.
이 DJI 브랜드에 대해서는 시선 님 어떻게 생각하시는지 궁금합니다.
놀라운 브랜드죠.
놀라운 브랜드.
네.
드론도 좋아하세요?
그럼요.
역시 안 좋아할 리가 없지.
DJI는 보통 제품 만드는 사람 입장에서 봐도 제품 잘 만들어요.
기획부터 시작해서 소비자들이 뭐 원하는지도 알고 그리고 단점도 있어요.
약점도 있어요.
약점이요.
예를 들면 DJI가 영상 분야에 드론 때문에 진출하게 됐는데 드론에 다 카메라가 달려 있잖아요.
근데 그 영상이 영상의 퀄리티로 보면은.
네.
화질이 있고 화소수가 있거든요.
근데 화소수나 이런 것도 되게 높은데 화질은 많이 떨어져요.
제가 보기에는.
그건 색감이라든지 그런 어떤 아날로그적인 부분이랄까 소프트웨어적인 부분이랄까.
그래서 핫셀블라드를 인수를 했죠.
보완하기 위해서.
많이 좋아졌고 그거 말고는 지금 현재 어디가 폼이 제일 올라와 있냐를 볼 수 있거든요.
DJI가 제일 올라와 있는 회사 중에 하나.
그러니까 딱 그 경쟁사랑 비교해 봤을 때 제일 넘사벽인 폼을 가지고 있는.
네. 맞아요.
이쯤에서는 재무제표 한 번 짚고 넘어가면 좋을 것 같은데.
지금까지 이야기한 기술력 좋은 중국 제조사들 DJI, 로보락도 있고 요즘 상황이 어떤지 궁금하네요.
네. 일단 여러 회사 중에 말씀하신, 극찬해주신 DJI 같은 경우는 아쉽게도 아직은 비상장사여서 정확한 숫자 확인은 어려운데 잘 성장할 거라고 생각이 들고요.
정말 잘하는 회사 중에 하나가 샤오미.
샤오미.
샤오미 같은 경우는 실적도 되게 좋고 일단 실적 한 번 보면 샤오미 같은 경우는 2022년에 56조, 그 다음에 54조를 하는데 24년에 74조를 팝니다.
그러니까 1년에 거의 20조의 매출액이 뛰는데 그 이유는 기본적으로 스마트폰도 점점 성능이 좋아지고 있고 플러스 전기차가 작년에 런칭을 했는데 나름 성공적으로 중국 시장에서 안착을 했습니다.
그 결과 매출액도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도.
영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 확 늘어가고 영업이익도 5조 원 수준, 영업이익률이 아직 74조 원이라는 매출액에 비해서 10%가 넘을 정도로 높지는 않은데 성장률이 좋다 보니까 이 회사도 주가가 홍콩 시장에 최근에 한 44달러 정도 되는데 주가가 한 3배 가까이 오를 정도로 샤오미는 요즘 분위기가 되게 좋은 회사고 샤오미는 특히 사업 보고서를 진짜 잘 만들더라고요.
그래요? 중국 기업인데도 장난 없이.
센서티브하게 잘 만들어요.
그러니까 뭔가 외부 투자자가 보고 싶어하는 어떤 숫자들을 굉장히 잘 만들어서 놀랐습니다.
예를 들어서 연구비.
R&D 비용이 우리가 어떻게 올라가는지 그래프를 맨날 보여주거든요.
그래서 2020년부터 지금까지 연구비가 매년 27%씩 상승을 해요.
또 재미있는 게 이 회사는 가전회사 중에 거의 유일하게 MAU를 공시하는 회사입니다.
MAU를 공시해요?
네, MAU를 공시해요.
MAU가 뭐예요? 모바일 앱의 MAU.
그러니까 모바일 앱이라기보다는 사용자?
생태계를 되게 강조하는 것 같아요.
아, 생태계.
그래서 이 회사 되게 무서운 회사다.
그래서 연구개발 진짜 열심히 하고 생태계 기반으로 유저를 확보하는 게 이 회사한테 정말 중요한 숫자라고 느껴서
샤오미가 되게 무서운 회사라는 걸 최근에 저도 숫자 보면서 느꼈던 것 같고요.
또 요즘 잘하는 회사 중에 하나는 엔커.
엔커 뭐 하는 회사인지 아세요?
보조배터리.
충전기, 보조배터리.
많이 쓰죠. 가성비 좋죠.
충전기, 보조배터리 이런 거 만드는 회사인데
여기 매출액 큽니다.
여기 2024년에 3조 9,000억.
전년도에서 3조 3,000억으로 대략 한 20%대의 매출액 성장률 나오고
한 10% 이상대의 순이익률이 나오고 있고
그러니까 옛날에 충전기만 팔았던 회사에서 스마트 홈 기기라고 해서
로봇청소기, 무선 보안 카메라, 프로젝터 이런 식으로 좀 이렇게 다양하게 카테고리를 좀 늘려나가면서
기술력으로 괜찮다라고 인정받는 회사 중에 하나가 엔커인 것 같아요.
이런 식으로.
우리가 생각하는.
가전 카테고리는 잘 안 늘어날 것 같은데
로브럭 잘 크고 샤오미 잘 크고 엔커 잘 크네.
중국이 진짜 가전이 무섭게 크는구나라는 생각을 할 수 있었던 것 같아요.
아까 말한 것처럼 중국이 하드웨어적인 기술력도 굉장히 공격적으로 앞서 나가고 있고
지금 보고 있는 재무제표나 주가의 흐름도 보면 굉장히 잘하고 있는 건 맞는 것 같아요.
시선 위에 보시기에는 이런 소프트웨어 파워까지도 중국 브랜드들이 가질 수 있을 거라고 생각하시나요?
저는 당연히 그럴 거라고 생각하고
이미 많이 가지고 있어요.
아 이미?
찾아보면 재밌는 거 하고 있는 데는 다 중국 회사예요.
가전 뿐만이 아니고 자동차 전부 다.
그게 원래는 저는 이제 문화의 차이도 있고
그러니까 결국 사람이 쓰고 사람을 만드는 거기 때문에
그 사람이 살아온 과정과
그 사람이 어느 날에서 어떻게 살고 있는지 이런 게 되게 중요하거든요.
그래서 못 따라간다고 생각을 했었는데 그게 아니더라고요.
아마 경제적인 이유도 있는데.
경제적인 이유도 있을 것 같아요.
우리나라 다른 국가들보다는 젊은 층 인구가 많고 경제가 더 빠르게 성장하고 있으니까
새로운 거를 냈을 때 반응하는 속도가 다른 거지.
젊은 사람들이 있으니까 새로운 게 나왔을 때 반응도도 빠르고
구매력도.
어 구매력도 점점 올라가고 있고
그러다 보니 시장은 또 워낙 크고
근데 지금은 이제 그런 아까 말했던 샤오미라든지 샤오미도 물론 카피로 시작했지만
특허를 굉장히 많이 가지고 우리가 우리의 어떤 기술입니다를 이제 외부에 보여주기 위해서 노력을 많이 하는 게 아주 장기적으로.
아주 장기적으로 보면 아 그거는 그 어떤 중국의 어떤 나쁜 이미지는 좀 어느 정도 희석될 수는 있겠다.
하지만 정치 제도로 인한 근본적인 한계는 아 그건 좀 쉽지 않겠다 라는 두 가지 양가적인 감정이 있습니다.
어쨌든 이렇게 대표적인 가전 브랜드들의 주가나 실적들을 좀 살펴봤는데
확실히 중국 브랜드들의 어떤 성장 중국 브랜드들의 어떤 강점 이런 것들이 굉장히 분명하게 보이고
우리나라는 약간 이제 좀 한국 브랜드들은 좀 완만한.
너무 완숙하다.
정체되어 있는 그런 좀 모습을 본 것 같아요.
그럼 가전 상황 시장을 좀 바꿔 논의를 좀 확장해서
이제 가전이냐 아니냐 카테고리가 무의미해질 거라고 하셨잖아요.
앞으로 이 시장이 좀 어떻게 바뀔 거라고 보시나요?
저는 오히려 가전 시장이 그런 계기로 인해서 더 커질 거라고 봐요.
오히려 더 커질 거다.
아마 기존에 니치마켓에 있었던 여러 가지 군들이 있는데
그게 다 가전의 메인마켓으로 들어서지 않을까 이런 생각도 해보고
예를 들면 오븐 같은 걸 보면 오븐의 브랜드가 울프냐 삼성이냐 어디냐
그거보다 거기에 안성재식의 굽는 방법이 들어갔냐가 더 중요하게 될 것 같아요.
그렇죠.
그래서 지금 그러니까 안성재가 광고를 한 제품냐가 아니라
그러니까 안성재라는 이름이 오븐 브랜드보다 더 중요하게 되는 시기가 분명 올 것 같아요.
그게 AI하고 결합이 되면 그게 가능하게 되는 거고.
그게 맞습니다.
취향이 더 뚜렷해지는 거군요.
맞아요.
그래서 사람들이 아마도 브랜드를 보고 샀던 이유도
저 브랜드가 내 취향하고 비슷한 제품들을 많이 만든다고 생각을 했었기 때문일 텐데
그렇지 않을 수 있거든요.
근데 앞으로는 그런 취향을 진짜 담고 있는지를 사람들이 확인하게 될 거고
그 취향에 맞는 제품들을 고르게 되는 시기가 오지 않을까.
콘텐츠가 AI가 있어야 되는 이유예요.
AI가 있어야 되는 이유다.
네.
콘텐츠가 아니면 AI가 필요 없죠.
그래서 제일 중요한 게 되지 않을까.
브랜드의 주의가 조금 낮아질 수 있다.
네.
그거보다 더 중요한 것들이 많이 있고
소비자들이 값어치를 브랜드보다는 말씀드린 그런 뭐랄까 콘텐츠라든지
취향이라든지 이런 게 훨씬 중요하게 되기 때문에
그게 브랜드의 위에 있지 않을까 그런 생각합니다.
이 이야기도 해보면 좋을 것 같아요.
그러니까 AI 기술에 대한 굉장히 큰 낙관론 같아요.
그러면은 기대가 크신 것 같고.
그럼 AI가 사람의 취향이나 큐레이션 같은 것도 대신할 수 있다고 생각을 하시나요?
당연히 대신할 수 있죠.
실제로 대신하고 있고요.
제가 항상 궁금했던 게 저처럼 제품을 잘 골라낼 수 있을까.
이게 어떻게 보면 되게 주관적인 거기 때문에 잘하고 못하기가 문제가 아니라
어떤 취향을 가진 나의 시선식의 어떤 제품을 골라낼 수 있을까.
AI가.
네.
그런 게 굉장히 궁금해요.
그런 게 굉장히 궁금했었거든요.
근데 최근에 해보니 아주 비슷하게 하더라고요.
해봤다는 거는 실제 시도를 해보셨나요?
그렇죠.
에이전트도 돌려보고 이것저것 해봐서
내가 생각하는 제품을 셀렉트하는 거 비슷하게
그 제품을 골라낼까 이런 것들을 테스트해보거든요.
해보는데 아주 비슷하게 해내요.
1년 전하고 6개월 전하고 지금하고 비교하면 큰 차이가 있어요.
그게 무슨 얘기냐면.
6개월 후나 1년 후에는 아마도 그 어떤 한계점이랄까 그걸 넘지 않을까.
저랑 되게 비슷한 깜짝 놀랄 만한 그래서 그거는 반드시 그렇게 될 것 같은 생각이 저는 들고 있습니다.
나의 시선이 보시기에는 어쨌든 AI 시대가 오면 그래서 가전시장이 큰 빅뱅을 겪고 전환을 겪고 나면 가전시장은 더 재밌고 니치하고 취향이 가득한 아주 다양성이 확보된 재밌는 시장이 될 것 같으세요? 아니면은 모두에게.
네.
그냥 아주 높은 만족도와 편의성만 주는 아주 플랫한 시장이 될 거라고 보세요?
어...저는 무조건... 전자구요.
전자...
네... 재밌는 시장이 될 것 같고요.
세상은 항상 나쁜 쪽으로 발전하지 않으니까.
좋은 쪽이라고 보면은 사람들이 진짜 원하는 것들이 뭔지를 만들어내겠죠.
그리고 그게 어쩌면 지금 중국이라든지 그런 소위 후발주자들?
보다 우리가 더 잘해야 되는 부분인 것 같아요
그런 부분들이
원래 사람은 다르잖아요
다 다르기 때문에 사실은 우리가 다 다른 제품을 쓰고 있어야 되는데
어떻게 보면 생산 어떤 설비나 어떤 구조의 한계 때문에
우리가 같은 아이패드를 쓰고
같은 스마트폰을 쓰고 있는 상황인 건데
근데 결국은 이제 사람이 다르다는 건
아마 기계가 학습을 통해 알게 될 거고
생산 비용은 시간 이루어질수록 절감될 거거든요
왜냐하면 그동안은 어떻게 보면
이거를 대량 생산을 통해 원가 절감을 해야 되지만
생산이 꼭 한 회사가 대량으로 하는 게 아니라
다양한 회사가 외주 생산하는 것들이
좀 이제 활성화된다고 한다면
제품은 앞으로도 맞춤으로
다양하게 조금 더 우리한테
재밌는 시장이 될 수도 있겠다는 생각이 저도 들으면서 정리가 되네요
AI를 사용하는 건 저는 항상
뭔가를 효율화하고
뭔가를 다 똑같이 다 좋게 하고
그냥 아주 통일화되는 그런 느낌이라고 생각을 했는데
오히려 말씀하신 것처럼
더 니치하고 더 재밌고
더 다양성하고
추구하기 위한 방향성의 AI가 있다는 사실은
좀 신선하게 다가왔던 것 같아요
소비문화의 면의 경제 이야기 비주류 경제야
오늘은 나의 시선님과 함께 가전 이야기를 나눠봤고요
저희는 다음 시간에 다른 주제로 돌아오겠습니다
감사합니다